foreign
let's go to Gainesville Florida and talk
to
Jackie what's up Jackie
hi John how are you good what are you
doing
not much just sitting on my lunch break
your lunch for oh I guess where I got
some hours differences
yeah just one hour very cool all right
so what's up
so my question for you is how do you
move on from toxic family members that
you've cut out of your life
um I have this issue where I have cut
out my dad for being very toxic and
um it's been over a year
but I still find myself going on
Facebook and looking through like my
grandma's profile his mom
to see what he's up to I find myself
looking at the settings on my phone
because you can see your blocked
messages and I'll look be like has he
contacted me and so I've done some
self-reflection about it and I think
I've gotten to the point where I feel
like I need to be validated in my
decision to do that
um
but
I don't think that's the right way to
find that validation and I don't know if
you would be able to help me out with
that yeah I think I can
um and thank you for sharing that that's
You Are Not Alone sister Jackie there
you that's such a common response to the
hard Brave thing you did which is to set
down boundaries what happened like there
was some moment when you said enough is
enough you've been dealing with this
your whole life
and it escalated what happened why'd you
finally say no more
got pregnant with my first
okay and
and strict different states and most of
our Communications through text
um when I was growing up I watched him
be sort of abusive towards my
ex-stepmom and he was emotionally
abusive manipulative and
um
so I went through all that and I see him
he's kind of like my bear like he I'm
uncomfortable around him talking to him
and stuff okay and as I got older and
started a family of my own
um
I realized like the negativity that he
brings into my life
was just too much and when I was
pregnant I realized it kind of escalated
and then I got pregnant with my second
and
I just realize he's not the type of
person I wanted around my kids if I'm so
uncomfortable around him absolutely and
so oh sorry so did a thing finally
happen
did he say the wrong thing did he swear
at you or did he make a comment about
your husband like what happened
all the time
um well not all the time it'd be like
months in between but every time we
would text he eventually would get to
the point like I wish we were better I
wish you would get over what happened in
the past and I would tell him
um I'm sorry that's something that I'm
working on I'm in therapy and
um he would blame me for not contacting
him more and he would even blame my mom
which he divorced 20 years ago that she
like
put me against him and everything he's
the one that would bad mouth my mom
while I was growing up so let me tell
you this
your your dad is a child
and your dad's a coward
and he cares more about his
him propping up his own ego to himself
than he does about his relationship with
his daughter and his new grandkids
and those are things you have felt for a
long long time probably no one's ever
said him like that
and I know it's hard to hear but it's
the truth and if you don't hear that
you're going to continue to think you're
crazy for protecting yourself and your
little kids and you're not
because that man's going to use you and
now he's going to use your grandkids
to prop up his own ego like he's tried
to do for so long you know what what
matters 20 years ago not a lot
I'm way more concerned that he hasn't
gotten his car and driven to your house
and knocked on your door
with tears in his eyes
and said I'm so sorry I'm your dad
and more so than any of my stupid
arguments or blaming you I should have
shown up and been your dad and I wasn't
I'm sorry
he doesn't do that
he launches Text Grenades at you every
once in a while and they burrow into
your heart and then you feel crazy
right
so what you did was the right thing and
I want to just for all the people
listening
you did something
um that was so wise
um and I want to just call it out
you don't like who you become when
you're around him
and often that impacts our children more
so than any dumb comment or anything
like that
they know that walking into this house
mom begins to feel like X or act like X
or she becomes why and then these kids
get unmoored by that and so you saying I
don't like who I become around you
I'm stepping out of this thing
good for you I'm proud of you Jackie
it's hard what you did and I'm proud of
you
now here's the next part
I can I can ask you this question but
we'll just cut to the chase
you've spent a lifetime being told that
what you believe is not trustworthy what
you feel is not trustworthy
oh isn't that the truth okay especially
by him there you go so it makes a
hundred percent sense that you finally
acted and you don't trust yourself
so you did the right thing
Okay so
recognizing that is part one
part two is acting differently now okay
so I don't want to overthink this
get off social media
or block your grandmother too
and start having human to human
conversations make it to where you there
was a season I was out of control with
my spinning I was just a maniac man we
finally make I was finally getting a
real paycheck for the first time in my
life and I was just Bonkers and at some
point I took my debit card out of my
wallet and gave it to my wife
I I had that little self-control
and I had to show up to a few places
where I'd already eaten and I realized
afterwards I didn't have my you know I
mean because it was just a I learned the
hard way but that's what that was how
drastic I got I think that's where you
are because here's what you have to do
you have to practice trusting yourself
and you've never done that before
and your kids need you to do that your
husband needs to do that you need to do
that
but if you've got that prop that crutch
to fall back on to see is he screwing
something up is he being a knucklehead
is he still with that woman whatever the
thing is that you keep going back
um you're gonna keep doing it
you got to practice
is that fair
yeah let me ask you this
um well I'll just say it this way brene
Brown calls it rehearsing tragedy
do you sit
um and I love that it's just a dress
rehearsal for for a tragedy
how often do you sit and just have
imaginary conversations with this guy
all the time
how often do you have imaginary
conversations with your mom like she's
finally gonna just ask you that one
right question and you're gonna unload
she's like my best friend she already
knows everything okay so
rumination just spinning out thinking
about it thinking about it thinking
about it that feels like good helpful
thinking
it feels like there's a Potential Threat
down the road and we're going to think
through how we're going to respond ahead
of time
the idea of it sounds good
hear me say this is as boldly as I can
rumination and worry is a complete and
utter waste of your time
in fact it steals from your children it
steals from your partner it steals from
you
because it takes you from the present
and it spins your body up your body
actually goes to war for you
it actually it's it's like oh there's
not even a bear here
um but we can conjure one up in our
brains and then we can respond to it
and you see what I'm saying and you get
out of the shower and you've been
sitting there having these imaginary
conversations in the shower for some
reason I hear all over the country
people have these in the shower I think
usually that's finally when people get
still enough in a day where they can
just that water's relaxing a little bit
and then they can the machine just kicks
up right me too
so listen Jackie I wish it was more
complicated than this quit
quit
stop having an imaginary conversations
with your dad that you are never gonna
have in real life
as my friend Todd says he doesn't have a
meteorite plan
so if a meteorite comes we will he will
deal with the economic Fallout of that
when it happens
and I'll tell you your dad's probably
not going to knock on your door and say
I'm so sorry
do you forgive me he's probably not
and so feel free to deal with that if it
ever happens it probably won't
and stop giving him rent-free space in
the middle of your chest
stop giving him rent-free space in the
middle of your marriage in the middle of
your parent of your kids in the middle
of your of your heart and head is that
fair
yeah it is
you're entering into the holiday season
right we're going to get into October
November December
is going to be extra hard is it
yeah especially if I'm thinking about
visiting the family in that state don't
why would you do that
because I love everybody else
do you get anxious when you're around
them
mainly him okay if he's there don't go
okay
because then you're just you know what I
mean you're trying to have your kidney
too you drew a boundary maybe at some
point you let them know I've chosen to
not be around him because these
gaslighting and manipulative and abusive
and he still won't take any ownership of
the way he treated me and my family
um and if you all choose to invite him
then then y'all are choosing for us to
not come and that's totally cool you can
do that you can put the ball in their
Court
but I don't see anything wrong with you
taking a year off
and just deciding opting for solving for
peace this holiday season
and that means you're gonna have to
grieve it you're gonna be sad you're
going to miss out on to this and that's
and you can't just do nothing you got to
backfill it with then we're going to go
here we're gonna go do this thing or
we're gonna go try this thing but do
something else
give your heart and mind and soul and
home arrest
is that possible
does that sound like ah or like what are
you feeling when I'm saying this
it does sound like ax
um it sounds like ah like scared or ah
like peaceful
um specific but uh it's peaceful
definitely peaceful
oh dude solve for solve for freedom
foreign
peace
it's all for sleep
which you probably don't have enough of
with two little ones right
oh absolutely not
what about just having a peaceful
holiday season
and all you have to do is just send an
email to your family says hey we're not
traveling this this year
I have a very different situation with
my family like I love my family like
hanging out with them
um and I sent the email yesterday
to all of them that said I let myself
get out of control last fall with all my
travel and I had a book deadline dude it
just got chaotic and then hosting the
holidays I became someone I don't like I
didn't like I wasn't the dad I wanted to
be the family member of the friend the
husband I wasn't I wasn't the guy one to
be so this year we're not hosting
and so I'm letting you all know way up
way in advance three or four months you
all need to buy plane tickets and come
out here we're not going to do a big old
thing
um we're gonna come to your house on
this day if y'all can make it great if
you don't if that's not a good time for
all we won't come
but we just decided all right I decided
man I need I need to recalibrate I need
peace
and then I'm gonna figure out how I can
best honor my family on the back end of
that see what I'm saying so maybe this
year you write your family letters tell
me love them and you miss them and wish
them well and send them a note says
we're not going to travel this year and
then just
whoo relax right
right
that sound good
it does it's I guess um it can be a
little heartbreaking not being able to
see everybody else and do you get that a
heartbreak is okay
how fun it's not pleasant but it's right
like it makes sense that you're
heartbroken
most the time when somebody puts up we
put up a boundary with somebody who's um
blown up our lives
we don't recognize the impact of that
boundary and still until people start
banging their head up against it and
what I mean by that is we like we think
that we can put up a boundary around one
person one friend one Community member
one husband or ex-wife or one you know
somebody struggling with addiction
whatever that is
um
but we don't realize that you can't very
rarely can you put up a boundary around
somebody in isolation it usually impacts
an entire system and your body's gonna
have to get used to the fact that you're
dead blew up everything
right
right and blaming him and sitting there
wallowing in that and getting mad at it
that doesn't solve any of your issues
what solves your issues is saying cool
I'm not going to be around that I'm not
gonna have my kids around that I'm going
to create something new and that's
annoying and hard and I don't want to
but that's what I'm going to do I'm
gonna
do something new
and I'm gonna solve for Freedom not like
Freedom not like political not I'm gonna
solve for peace I'm gonna solve for
sleep I'm gonna solve for
rest I'm going to solve for laughter I'm
gonna solve for kindness and patience
I'm gonna solve for whoo
maybe we could all use a little bit more
of that
thanks for the call Jackie